you hear about what Bank of England
warned of yesterday Bank of England
warns of longest recession in 100 100
years as it raises rates to three
percent
uh that's not very much of an optimistic
message coming from the bank of England
three quarters of a basis point increase
the latest in a series of eight interest
rate hikes since last year would not be
enough to guarantee victory in a war
against double legit inflation the bank
of England said as it a cautioned
further action would be needed the UK
economy faces a very challenging Outlook
with a recession that began this summer
now expected to last the middle of 2024
with the possibility of a general
election being held in 2024 the
conservatives face campaigning to remain
in government at the tail end of a
prolonged slump during which the bank
said it expected unemployment rates to
rise from three and a half to six and a
half percent so and if they're saying
that double that's going to happen here
as well next year in unemployment we're
not there yet though so but Tom what
does that mean if Bank of is saying this
well I think what you see here at the
bank of England is you have a Frank
assessment of what is actually happening
in our economy we there you know they
say oh don't call it a recession we're
not going to do that we're going to
change the definition look what's going
on over here we're already seeing the
interest rates raise we've already had
the multiple uh multiple UPS we're
seeing we were just talking about the
jobs report that the jobs report was
really uh talking about low-end jobs
that the 10.7 million was low in jobs
what you're seeing there you know that
is uh that is exactly what is happening
here we're just not willing to to say it
we're just now willing to say it we're
not willing to say it yeah it's the
things like things yeah I mean I think
that um again my mind flashes back to
the in the in the in the late 80s 90s we
had this profession called the economics
profession and you had economists on the
left and on the right but they weren't
all that far apart on the facts they
disagreed about sometimes their
interpretation they would disagree for
example on the effect of inflation on
interest rates
um but there was about inflation by the
way this word Republicans been using
lately what is the do you guys know the
meaning of uh Tyler what does this mean
Joy Reid said republi you know people
some a lot of people don't know what
this word inflation means can you pull
up the definition if I have to interrupt
you because some of us are not from
America here I was born in Iran
what is the definition of inflation go
to definition of inflation because
apparently only the folks on the left
know what the meaning of inflation is in
economic inflation is increases in the
price of goods and services in an
economy got I just want to verify that's
our audience knows that but go ahead
right I mean the key thing about
inflation is that you have the same
number of goods that then cost more
across the board and that's that's
inflation uh because because essentially
what it means is your money is losing
value right so for example if you have a
hundred dollars in your pocket and you
can buy a hundred dollars worth of stuff
and there's ten percent of inflation in
effect you now have ninety dollars in
your pocket even though you still count
100 that's the point of what inflation
is and and uh but what I was saying was
that this body of economic knowledge
appears to have almost vanished and I
don't know if it's because the
economists are now muted and their
influence is reduced so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
[Music]